hello again well joining us now in the
studio is the shadow foreign secretary
edna Thornbury hello thanks for being
with us
and so Jeremy Corbyn this weekend has
said I can still be Prime Minister this
is still on do you think he can still be
Prime Minister yeah let's see what
happens let's see what happens what do
we got we've got we've got Theresa May
squatting in Downing Street
we've got a full rebellion going on in
the Conservative Party we've got no idea
as to what's going to be in this Queen
speech you know they have a manifesto
that's completely been repudiated by the
public and indeed by Tory MPs themselves
no idea what the DUP is going to agree
to or not so any proper government them
yeah we have to be we have to be
absolutely on our toes you accept Lee
lost the election there well no I don't
think that we did I think that we did
extraordinarily well and I think we had
and votes from the comparative yes but
we but but what's clear from our side is
that is that we have a surge of support
for our manifesto and for our
alternative vision of what Britain could
be like and we have a much stronger
mandate for that than frankly the Tories
do what are the Tories stand for now who
knows but that just that's not the same
as winning an election there with it yes
but you know let's see how the Tories do
let's see if they're able to hold it
together and if not we will step up we
would love the opportunity to serve okay
maybe you can help me out with some of
the massive mass was never my strong
point I will admit so if you do do with
the SNP they've got 35 MPs convinced the
Lib Dems will support you it's another
12 Greens have got one plied Comrie for
Jeremy Corbyn persuades Jim fain to come
over to Westminster which give you a
handful more even then you still only
have 321 seats that's not a majority
unless you get into bed with the DUP
which is what you criticize the
conservatives for doing we're not
getting into bed with anybody we would
be an alternative government we would be
a minority government we would put
forward our Queen speech which is
incredibly popular
you know our policies are popular our
policies of what the country wants we
would put forward a Queen's speech we
were put forward a budget and it would
be up to the other parties and indeed
some conservative MPs to decide if they
wanted to support it or not but how can
you put together a minority government
when you've got so many fewer seats in
the concert
let's see let's see I mean we're in
uncharted territory all I'm telling you
is that we are our manifesto is popular
our vision for Britain is right they
have no idea of what they're doing
we are waiting in the wings we will step
in if we are required and if we are
called upon to serve so in a month time
do you think Jeremy Corbyn could be a
number 10 who knows let's see that's
certainly leaving door open yeah
you see you lost the election campaign
even though I know that for many it
feels like a win because she you know
increased your seats by about a million
votes against what many people feel was
one of the worst political campaigns in
history I mean what does that say about
the state of the labour party if you
couldn't even beat Theresa May and a
campaign that by all accounts with a bit
of a disaster let me tell you this
Sophie when you look at the polls today
it would seem that we are five points
ahead of the Conservatives I think we're
going to go through a period where
labour will become increasingly popular
and the reason is this not just because
we are united behind our policies but
actually we show what the Labour Party
can be if we are united and the Tories
in the meantime are falling apart we
have learnt over the last couple of
years that a disunited party is an
unpopular party what we show during the
election is just what a force we can be
if we stick together and that is what we
can do because frankly there is very
little that we disagree on within the
labour party and we have to remember
what we agree on and we have to take the
fight to the Tories you talk there about
a disunited party what would you say to
the people in labour over the last
couple of years who have publicly
doubted Jeremy Corbyn who launched
leadership contests against him who
organized votes of no confidence in him
what they underestimated him and I think
may accept that so you know let's put
that behind us and let's look forward
because that's what's important we look
forward we look forward together you
must feel a sense of getting things
right though but they've got it wrong
and you've got it right I don't feel
that I feel really pleased that we have
done as well as we have and I think that
we are on the verge of government and
that is fantastic would you welcome some
of those critics back to the front bench
I think that we need to use all our
talents there are lots of different
things that people can do but yes we
have to be a United Party it's up to
Jeremy you know who does what but
of course we have a range of talents and
experience and we need to use them
you're someone who is very close to
Jamie call when you work very closely
with him your neighboring constituencies
are you getting the feeling that he is
preparing to reach out to some of those
people who've been perhaps left on their
back benches all I can say is that
Jeremy's approach has always been one
where he has tried to be as inclusive as
he possibly can be and I'm sure he'll
continue to do that so that's the
estimate I'm telling you it's not my job
as Jeremy's job and let's talk a bit
about the situation that the
Conservative Party find them in
themselves in now with DP how do you
feel about the prospect of this
agreement between the Conservatives and
the DP I don't know what it means and I
don't understand what it means I don't
know what the deal is and that's that is
what is so extraordinary you know the
Tories have won the election and yet we
don't know what it is that they're going
to do and they don't even know what
they're going to do nobody has any idea
what's going to be in there Queen speech
Theresa May doesn't know she has to go
into negotiations with Philip Hammond it
seems he's supposed to be her Chancellor
of the Exchequer I'm if they are in
disarray so we do not know what is going
to happen next
so it's very difficult for me to
critique it in that way there is one
thing that concerns me and that is the
role of the government in the Good
Friday Agreement because it's written
into the Good Friday Agreement that the
the government should be scrupulously
impartial in relation to the two sides
and that's kind of hard isn't it if
you're in coalition with one of the two
sides I mean there might be crisis that
might come up
we're heading for thee for the marching
season and there have been times when
the Secretary of State has had to step
in in order to ensure that there that
that piece is kept on the streets
obviously nobody wants to see a
situation where the Secretary of State
is embarrassed and feels that he has to
trade off the coalition with potential
problems in Northern Ireland enormously
though if you were in the same position
as Theresa May when you'd be looking to
do precisely the same deals with the
Brits that talks days away that you need
to have
a majority in government I would never
be in the position of Teresa may she did
not need to call this election she
called this election in order to get rid
of the opposition she said that she
wanted to have a mandate what kind of
mandate does she now have if I was
Theresa May I would be resigning if she
got more votes than jeremy corbyn's they
shouldn't Jeremy called me would be
resigning as well he lost the election
no no it's a City question yes sorry now
let's talk a bit more about those brexit
negotiations because these that is the
big issue now facing the country do you
think Theresa May should be the one
sitting down in front of those
representatives from Brussels and
leading those tours it's very difficult
I think that it's not really about
personalities on this more than what's
in the interests of the country now I've
been saying for the last year ever since
the Edison SAR referendum that the best
way of approaching this is to do it with
the maximum support that you can that
you can garnish so that's why I said to
them put forward a plan put forward a
plan at an early stage let's talk about
it in Parliament let's have a United
position and they simply haven't been
able to do that because they've been
trying to manage internal problems
within the Conservative Party what we
have said is that the way in which you
can bring the brexit you know people who
voted to leave and people who voted to
remain together is by putting forward a
clear policy which is about the economy
which is about jobs first we should have
jobs first strong brexit that's what we
should be working together on now that's
what I think the right approaches the
difficulty is is that it's very
difficult to work with them because that
is clearly not what they want they want
you know if they go into this with no
deal is better than whatever is a bad
deal as well whatever I mean that they
are they're contemplating not having a
deal at all and just walking away that
would be really damaging for our economy
and for our country and that is quite
clear they need I mean we have six Tests
if they want to work on our six Tests
with us I wouldn't have a problem with
that but as I say I think that they are
so far apart from us I think it would be
very difficult for us to work together
would it be so difficult though if you
did get a call from Boris Johnson for
example
saying he wants to get around the table
with you and kiss Dharma and David Davis
from Conservative Party would you be
open to that
yeah listen Oh in a few years ago we got
the call on social care from the Tories
and they said let's work together and
working out what the answer to Social
Care was and we went I went to number 10
and we began the negotiations and the
Tories pulled out I mean you know in
good faith of course we would go into it
but we have a clear idea of what we want
from Breck said and frankly the Tories
are all over the place so it should be
you who reaches out hand and writes the
letter to Boris Johnson to say let's get
round the table they claim that they're
in government let them begin it it would
have to be their initiative okay and now
you're shall a foreign secretary
you speak to representatives from
different countries all the time what is
their reaction been to this general
election diffic I'm not spoken to
anybody in relation to oh actually no I
spoke to Martin Schulz but apart from
Elton Schulz who's the is the leader of
the left in in Germany I have not spoken
to anybody yet
I mean clearly there's there's great
concern about it they want to get a good
deal for Britain for brexit and a good
deal for Europe and they're concerned
about the chaos that is currently
happening in in Britain but you they
want to get on with the negotiations so
if there is that chaos and you do they
do want to get on with the negotiations
which I'm assuming is what you want as
well is it right for labour to be
effectively calling for Theresa May to
resign what we're calling for is a
United position on brexit around our six
Tests and around a jobs first brexit
that's what our position has been it's
been you know absolutely throughout and
if the last year we're all united about
that we have had we've been made that
clear throughout this election that's
what we stand for that's what the
negotiations should be based on what do
you think that the election result means
the brexit now going forward I mean if
there was a vote for example on leaving
the single market would Labour supporter
we have said that it is it is difficult
for us to remain technically in the
single market if we're leaving the
European Union we are leaving the
European Union so we need to remain as
close as we can to the economy of Europe
because so many of our jobs depend on it
and half of our traders with the
European Union so we need to begin on
that position and people get a bit hung
up about whether we're technically in
the single market or not but what we
have said is that we want to have a
tariff free red tape free access to the
market so is the Norway model on the
table then where you have to accept free
movement of people but you can still
have that memory of the single market
that unfortunately we are not in
government we are not leading the
negotiations we have we have made clear
what our priorities are it's important
what your view is because of the okay
situation in the house call but I mean
let me just let me just preface what I'm
saying with that and so we have said
that we're leaving the European Union
that we will be responsible for our own
borders that we will make sure that we
have fair rules and we will have managed
migration and and that needs to be there
but we need to balance the needs of our
economy with the needs of our
communities when it comes to immigration
okay well it's been good to speak to you
said you seem happy with that election
result might need to work on the high
files for the term in Corbin though I'll
leave it that every tombery thank you
very much